now once you remember to help us seven
this morning and we looked at this guy
this was armed ex just papered equals T
squared minus four it was just an
example we started at initial condition
was four units or sorry four meters in
the negative direction from the origin
and then after two seconds we passed the
RNA then we just kept on going okay so
when we have a look at this this idea of
average velocity average speed etc all
we need to do with me just starting wage
and we just start wind and how longs it
take you to do that okay so when we will
look at average velocity for instance up
over the first two seconds right when
you calculated that x2 minus x1 1 T 2
minus 2 1 like I mentioned before
average velocity gives you the gradient
of the cord between these two spots on
the time displacement ground by the way
just a minor minor note this is a time
displacement graph you'll see you'll
hear it called the displacement time
graph sometimes because the important
feature about it is displacement but we
would usually say horizontal and the
vertical axis like X Y so I call this
time displacement okay the gradient of
that cord is the average velocity over
this interval of time okay but now that
we know calculus calculus takes gradient
and says you don't need to need to
points32 points you can just say it any
particular point like saying right there
okay with calculus I don't need to worry
about an interval I can find out the
gradient at a single instance on my
breath right so therefore that's what
takes us from average loss and
acceleration to instantaneous water use
acceleration and from now on basically
if you see these two words they mean
instantaneous they mean calculus if they
want you to work out the average now say
average okay so therefore if you've got
a situation where you know the
displacement as a function of time all
we need is to apply understanding
calculus that we've used in rates of
change already to come up with
expressions for each of these okay so
remember we said velocity
is how displacement is changing over
time so velocity V is simply equal to it
just go differentiate right I want to
know how X is changing as time is
changing okay now we said acceleration
is also really important it's how
velocity is changing over time so if i
call acceleration ay then I'm going to
take whatever that expression for
velocity was and then I'm going to
differentiate that okay so bossy
derivative with respect to time
obviously displacement acceleration is
the do with redstone or velocity but of
course because you can see all this is
so interconnected right I can link
acceleration directly to displacement to
see that I just have to differentiate
once with respect to time and then do it
again yeah so therefore what
acceleration represents is the second
derivative of displacement with respect
to time okay now because this starts to
get a little bit you know cumbersome and
physicists who want to use this they're
not actually worried about the calculus
they just once they get the Foreman's
they just use them and I don't worry
about actually nuts and bolts of the
algebra and so on they introduce
different kinds of notation which
indicate this is really about X
displacement changing over time they
call it X dot and this is how X's change
over time is changing over time so they
call it X double dot okay and you will
see all of these forms of notation um
just like when we introduce F dash in F
Double Dash notation my preference is
always to actually just write out what
the derivatives are or to say V or a
because they're pretty much an ambiguous
in this context however you need to be
able to recognize when they say x dot 4
X double dot what are they talking about
they mean first derivative with respect
to time second review with respect to
time at all now here's the right time
because we're really going to start to
learn that acceleration now properly to
get at the fact that acceleration has a
colloquial meeting and then
has a very very specific meaning in our
context okay so if I were to say to you
okay I'm in the car and my car is
accelerating okay colloquially what
would that mean what words could you
substitute that a simple art that would
mean the same thing I'm speeding up very
good I'm getting faster okay so
colloquial meeting here is speed is
increasing okay now along with this
color convening we have an opposite
what's the opposite of acceleration its
deceleration right so what we would say
is um if your speed is not increasing if
your speed is decreasing if you're
slowing down okay we would call that
decelerating right
okay so speeding up slowing down that's
what the clerk really is however you'll
notice that here it's actually right
that we talk about speed here whether
you're going before it or you're in
Reverse it doesn't matter you have speed
and you don't care about direction okay
so this is about distance and speed but
that's not really what calculus is
interested in right nor physics so
therefore in our context accelerate
means something quite different it means
this right it means how is velocity
changing with respect to time okay so
therefore in mathematics and physics
when you see the word accelerated you
should read into that velocity is
changing is it increasing where is it
decrease it doesn't matter it's changing
change it you can change in any
direction you like the sign of the
acceleration will tell you whether
you're getting faster or slower so
velocity spin scuze me velocity is
changing which means that really rather
say accelerate decelerate which you
should by the way never use the word
decelerate it's just too confusing and
has this quad-core mediatek so it's not
worth it okay so you will never hear me
except for this moment here talk about
decelerating in this context rather than
that I would say I am I am accelerating
in a positive or a negative direction
and in the context of the question that
might mean I'm accelerating up or down
I'm accelerating left or right or
whatever you want to define okay so
let's just think about this for a moment
let's come back to this guy so on this
graph right you can see the velocity is
positive okay there is acceleration also
happening because the velocity isn't the
same all the way through how do I know
Morse is not the same all the way
through when I look at the scrap the
gradients check your throat right so
being that the gradient is changing the
velocity is also changing so Flossie's
tell you that means there's acceleration
what direction is the acceleration in
it's in the positive direction right so
velocity is in the positive direction
acceleration also
in the positive direction so therefore
quickly we'd say oh that's why you're
speeding up so you're speeding up okay
now if I were to say take this graph
which is concave up right and maybe you
want to draw this on the side here as
well and if I were to have it yeah what
if I want to have a concave down like
this okay let me ask the same question
again which direction is velocity going
in it's still in the positive direction
isn't it it's still going up the x
values are still increasing okay so
velocity still that way but acceleration
is in the opposite direction right so
Caligula take all your slow me down but
all I really need to say is well the
acceleration is going to be negative if
I want to think back to geometrical
applications of happens I'd say it's
concave down the clean cavity is
negative right so that's all that means
it's all me in exactly the same way if I
kept going and I accelerated so much in
the negative direction that I turned
around okay this point right for you
what do you call this point we call it a
turning point because you do turn around
um even before its determine if I would
also call it a stationary point because
for that instant in time you're not
moving the velocity is not positive it's
not negative you're just flat stationing
but then your acceleration has pushed
you in opposite directions right so this
whole time you are accelerating in the
negative direction what would it look
like if acceleration was here if I
stopped accelerative you just be back in
a consequence it be at a constant
velocity nothing's slowing you down
accelerating the do darshan nothing's
speeding you are accelerating the
positive direction this object here is
experiencing no acceleration
does that make sense I